good morning Hank it's Sunday so your
video about the 13 severed hands of Star
Wars kind of blew my mind with its
brilliance
by the way nerdfighters if you haven't
seen it you should wake in the thingy
and when I was watching you showcase
your masterful knowledge of the Star
Wars universe I started to think like I
don't even know half of the severed
hands of Star Wars maybe I'm not even a
nerd
well hey cuz you can imagine the thought
that I wasn't a nerd was duly horrifying
but then I remembered that I've
memorized all the known last words of
American presidents George Washington
tis well John Adams it is the glorious
4th of July it is a great day it is a
good day and then he fell asleep and he
woke up later and said Thomas Jefferson
still survives which wasn't true Thomas
Jefferson had died earlier that same day
July 4th 1826 his last words were is it
the 4th actually those weren't his last
words those would have been great last
words but then he said I resigned my
spirit to God and my daughter to my
country
at which point his daughter was
presumably like dude you don't own me
you can't resign me to anybody I mean
like jeez dad do you believe that human
beings can own other human beings
oh right you do James Madison I always
talk better lying down James Monroe
speaking about James Madison I regret
that I should ever leave this world
without again beholding him John Quincy
Adams this is the last of the earth I am
content
Andrew Jackson be good children all of
you and strive to be ready when the
change comes no mention of which change
Martin Van Buren there is but one
reliance William Henry Harrison I wish
you to understand the true principles of
government I ask them to be carried out
I ask nothing more John Tyler dr. I am
going perhaps it is best James kapok
whose last words would be good last
words for me too I love you Sara I love
you for all eternity Zachary Taylor I
regret nothing but I am sorry that I'm
about to leave my friends the
underappreciated Millard Fillmore after
drinking a spoonful of soup famously
said the nourishment is palatable
Franklin Pierce tragically unknown James
Buchanan seemingly aware of the fact
that history would judge him one of the
worst presidents ever said I shall carry
to my grave the consciousness that at
least I meant well for my country Oh
Lord God as thou wilt Abraham Lincoln
said either it doesn't really matter or
they won't think anything of it as he
was trying to convince his wife that
they shouldn't be embarrassed about
holding hands in public Andrew Johnson I
need no doctor I can overcome my own
trouble
or not ulysses s grant water brother for
behaves I know I am going where Lucy is
James Garfield Swain can you stop this
Oh
Swain Swain was Garfield's chief of
staff but it occurs to me that Swain be
a pretty good substitute for dang like
Oh Swain and I stub my toe Chester a
Arthur unknown Grover Cleveland I have
tried so hard to do right Benjamin
Harrison dr. my lungs when William
McKinley's wife said I want to go to
McKinley answered we are all going Teddy
Roosevelt put out the light William
Howard town slaps words are unknown but
Woodrow Wilson's were I am a broken
piece of machinery when the machine is
broken
I am ready Warren Harding that's good go
on read some more Calvin Coolidge good
morning Robert
so off-topic but Calvin Coolidge was
famous for never saying anything and one
time this woman comes up to him and she
says so my friend bet me that I couldn't
get more than two words out of you at
which point Calvin Coolidge says you
lose Herbert Hoover levi-strauss was one
of my best friends
Franklin Roosevelt I have a terrific
pain in my head Harry Truman unknown
Dwight Eisenhower I'm ready to go God
take me John F Kennedy after being told
that Dallas loved him said that's very
obvious Lyndon Johnson's last words were
send Mike immediately neither Nixon nor
Reagan's last words were recorded all
other presidents are currently alive I
did it Hank you'll see me on Tuesday